un sens les victimes ont été piégés sur
une route en feu parti trop tard
comme ce couple qui serpente entre les
flammes d'un côté de la route de l'autre
du feu partout le réflexe faire une
prière notre père qui êtes aux cieux
mettez nous en sécurité la fumée qui
s'épaissit des voitures arrêtées sur le
bas côté
et puis après quelques centaines de
mètres la sortie de l'enfer
c'est la ville de paradise qui a été
partiellement détruite par l'incendié
on est dans le nord de la californie le
feu a réduit en cendres des dizaines de
maisons des véhicules
heureusement abandonnées par leurs
occupants et les flammes ne sont
toujours pas maîtrisés par les pompiers
gala s'il vous plaît partez n'est pas un
conseil c'est un ordre d'évacuation
qu'ont reçu soixante quinze mille
personnes près d'un autre incendie qui
menacent malibu au nord de los angeles
un terrain de football toutes les deux
secondes c'est la vitesse à laquelle ils
grossissent est aujourd'hui mais celui
ci n'a pas fait de victime depuis un an
la californie a vécu deux des pires
incendies de son histoire
si mathieu prost radio-canada à montréal